[音楽]
福浜中なんです本日は朝9時も話がありましたとおりまさに皆さんの価値というものを
はどのように上げていくのが世界というところで上げていくのかということについてお
話を差し上げたいという風に考えて打っています
頭で皆さん皆さん徒歩社会における価値というものはどのように
どのような基準で評価されるかということを考えたことがあるでしょうか
例えばリンゴの間1個のまあ価格
勝ちということであれば例えばリンゴの一つでの価値は100円というように
つーかというところであらわされるわけですよね
そうした時に人間である皆さん一人一人の価値というものはどのような形で示すことが
できるのかというところをぜひ今日の私はセッションで考えていただきたいなという
ふうに考えています
ここで一般的に社会の中におけるある人例えば皆さん一人一人の価値というものは周り
からの評価というところによっ
前からの評価という基準によって価値づけがされていくという現実があります
そうした中において皆さんはどのような基準でどの皆さんは一人一人が評価をされたい
のか
そして例えば皆さんも考えて頂きたいですが今例えば経営を付属の中でいる中で皆様今
の価値評価されているものに対してどれくらい満足なんっていうことも考えていきたい
なというふうに思います
ただ私が10校の学生だったときどのような価値に満足をしていたのかというと
10校の服版です
つまり慶應義塾という中にいる自分というものの価値そして基準というのはある意味 k
様であったり
学歴という基準での評価というものに満足していた自分というものがあるわけですね
これ大学においても同じような状況というものが続いていました
ところが実際の者数のあると海外の方でずっと仕事をしていたり学んでいくということ
になっていたわけですがその中でなかなかこの価値というものが世界の中でうまく
伝わっていかないということも現実に繰り返し
バーンもあっていくような形になったわけですね
そうした中の学者いろいろどのように自分というものを世界の中で価値を高めていけば
いいのかということを考えるようになってきました今日はその中のまあポイントですね
実際私はそのまだ世界中に置いてる自分の勝ちというまでまだた調にデザインし続けて
いるわけですけれども
ここまでーたものというものをみなさんとシェアしていきたいなというふうには
ますこれから3つについ3つの曲についてお話を差し上げたいと思います
まず私は慶應義塾大学の経済学部を卒業しそして金融機関を経てそして
まあフランスのですねまあ飲酒アドという世界中約70カ国から人々がクララ可能ま
大学院というものにも進学をしました
この中で最初に自己紹介を最初するわけですね
自己紹介するときにどういう自己紹介をしていたかというと慶應義塾大学出身です
そしてその軌道を投じに勤めていた金融機関の名前所属というものを言って自分の中勇
私にしてみると慶應義塾大学出身だぞ
you まあをも1機の非常に強かったわけですね
ところが世界中の人達の中でまず ko なんかを知っている人間がほとんどいない
わけです日本に来たことがある人間でもなければ ko などという名前は世界に知ら
れていない
そして私のようにどこの大学出ましたなんて言うような人間は他にはいなくて自分は
世界でこれだけの新しい価値をつくってきている
私は世界をこのように帰ってきますというより自己紹介ばっかりだったわけです
その時にあり一体この ko という自分にとっての価値 ko というところでつい
てが勝ちというのは何だったんだろうということを考えるようになっていった
なんかまずまさに重視5歳の時ということになります
後もう一つ衝撃的だということは何かというと
in シャードにっ実際に州私系よりも10頭だとか大学に入ってるときに特に成績と
かであまり問題になったことはなかな
普通に打っていればもどうにかなるなという思いはあったんですけれども
インチシャードにって何が起こったかというと全く何も通用しないんです
本当に落ちこぼれになっていってしまってチームワークマイン斜度というの新しい価値
をつくっていこうということをベースにしている大学院などで既にチーム
ディスカッションを重ねてチームの新しい価値をつくっていくということを繰り返し
ます
そうしたような中において何も発言もできなければ何も貢献できない自分というものが
いるわけで
stay
そうした中で一体自分はどうしてしまうんだろうでもそれだけで実は思っていたらや
大学めでとうにかなっていたからきっとこれは自分の英語力が問題であるに違いないと
いうふうに考えるようになっていました
そうしたがですね
あの360度という形で印象部の場合は1カ月に一回強化を周りの友人達がお互いに
ずっとつけ続けるんですね
君はこの1カ月間こういうことができたよともういうふうにこういう風にしたらどうか
というようなフィードバックの皇室だというフィードバックみたいな形でどんどん戻し
ていくということを行います
そういった中でもある意味それが人間というものがあらゆる角度から分析をされて
フィードバックをして成長していこうよということを言われるわけです
ただ私バスグループ活動においてほとんど発言ということもできない中でやっていた
わけですから
このグループのその発表の日に実は今でも覚えているんですけれども
病気になったふりをしてズル休みしてしまった日ですねどうせ悪い土地はれるよう
ところがこの点者として前歯まいますさん上位までずっと朝な朝方まで勉強し続けるん
ですが夜中の1時に
私のハートに保管グループメンバーが全員やってきて
でてこう言う
しっかりと違い評価しようです
いうような形でますまさに評価の場にまあ戻されるということになりました
そしてその中で当然のよみんなからリメイク人か言うわけですね
お前はこの1か月間何の価値も院車でください
を回る存在って一体何なんだどこお前は何か答えがあるっていうふうに勘違いしてるん
じゃないか
世の中に答えがある問題になってないんじゃない一緒にお前も一言議論もしていって
くれなければその答えがなにかあるみたいに思ってるお前自身というものの存在意義
なんてないど答えなんてないかということを言われました
そうかなぁと思いつつも同時に私はや英語力だよなというふうに思っていた中である私
の友人から一言を言われました
お前英語を言い訳にするのはいい加減にしろあるもしお前が回るように名は10分の1
しかできないんだったら中身を10万円してこう言う
そうしたらようやく一人前になれるだ
さらに日本人だから英語が母国ではないから何かに貢献しないということは全く世界と
いう場の中においては許されないんだよということを
世界の中でしっかりと自分の価値を出せよということを言われました私は多分人生を
通じてスペインちょっとまあ禁制という会社のすべてイティ
to do から一ゴロ
のであっそうなのかと
それまで ko というコミュニティという過去の専従の方々が作ってきた価値の中で
安住をしていたわけですけれどもそうではなく自分が新しいかそのブランドだけに頼る
ということではなく自分で新しい価値を作って行かなければ何の意味もないんだという
ふうに考え出したのがまさに
20主語のときで世界での表
かというものどのようにとっていこうか一人としてどのように畳かっていう風には考え
さという形になります
そして実際皆さんがこれから生きていく時代というものはなかなか日本そして ko と
いうブランドだけではなかなか耐えられないこれは多くも高校生や大学生に聞いても
いまだに日本の gdp のシェアを2割だとか
皆さんどうもという感じですね2割程度だと思って
人が多いわけですねまあ仕事でなかなかの4.14%しから
あと5年で3.55%まで imf の
そのデータによると日本の世界における gdp 者とこうしてくるわけですね
勝慶応での世界での学歴ランキングというのを601位から800
これが今のリアリティなわけです皆さんは10校というところで10校ありは経営の
保存保管口説こうという方々もいらっしゃると思いますけれどもこうしたブラウンだ
だけではなかなか生き残っていけないというのがリアリティとして世界の中では
つまり教訓の一つ系は素晴らしいコミュニティですけれどもそのコミュニティに頼って
生きていけると思ったのであれば
白世界の中においてはなかなか厳しいというものがということがまず最初に私どうか
伝えたいことになります
そして皆さんは
ai 人工知能全盛時だというものを生きていく形になります
a 全盛時代はこれからの30年はかこの30年と比べていろいろな意味において人間
の役割というものを再定義され大きな変化
今大産業革命の真っ只中というふうにはれていますが全く異なる時代というもの生きて
いく皆さんです
こうした皆さんというものが何を考えていかないといけないかというと子たった一つの
ものというものは ai が簡単に解いてしまうわけです
知識なんていうものは簡単に陳腐化してしまう例えば私も熟考の時に点数が発展事かあ
るったり発展なら人間ってにが特にいきますよねそれで凄いなぁと思ってましたけれど
も
実際今 ai は国会士試験に合格できるだけの力 ai 持ってこれじゃあ今日は
大学人工賃がそこまで作ってしまっているわけです
ですからそんなようなワットというものに関しては人間が人工知能に勝てるということ
自身を
をまさに昔のかこの30年のモデルでしかないわけです
そうした中で何が重要なのかというと答えが与えられているワットというものに関して
はもはや
人工知能に関わる勝てないわけです
より how に関わるコンピテンシ想像力だとか課題設定力忍耐いる
あるいは論理力といったようなまさにこういった今剣士というものをつけていくという
ことが大切になってきます
例えばこれどうやって付けられるかというとでも皆さん今日は店頭に出てきてくれ
いらっしゃってるわけですよね
例えばたんこういった課外活動にどんどん参加するというのは当然のプラス
ただし何気よく出ていてはダメで今日はこの今店仕様のバス
例えば今日は想像力を伸ばすために権利を聞くつまりアクティブリスニングができて
いるのか
ボーンよりリスニングをしているのかという違いというものが大きくてそれをどのよう
に皆さんを行っていくのかということが
これからの時代大きく変わってくるという形になりますね
教訓2つ目は里から how というまさにこれからの大産業革命時代には
パウにどのように対応していくのかということが重要になってきます
そして3つ目人工知能は人間の最大公約数的なところを生まれてきます
ただし人口中は子せよ
とするならば人間再提起されていくという中において皆さん一人一人の個性が大切に
なるわけですね
人とどれぐらい違う周りとどれくらい違うのか
これこそが皆さんの価値になっていくという時代に入ってきています
そしてそれを考えていくためには常に自分とは何者なのかという哲学的な問いかけと
いうものに占領こない
そしてこれはスタティックではないんですすでにダイナミックに新しい学びを続けて
いく中において自分とは何者なのかということを再形にしていく
走者セル再定義していく中において自分の絶対的な強みというものをつくっていくと
いうことが非常に重要な時代になってきています
そしてじゃあそれをやるためにはまさに中に2人のように皆さん思われるかもしれませ
んが
結局どれぐらいの方を選んだのかというところが一番大きく効いてきます
共用ですねでそれはなぜかというと過去数千年における人間の血が入ってるだけでは
なくみなさんは疑似体験できるわけです
人間がどういうようなことで血を流してきたどのようなことによって人間は様々な発見
をしてきたのかあぁこういうほど疑似体験しながら
すぎる未来というもの歴史に学ぶという非常に
大きいですしさらに未来に向けて新しい知見というものを得ていくということは非常に
大きいということになります
そして今回の ko テッドのおおきなけーまでもありますけれども
コネクティつまり自らのコミュニティいるということでは自らコミュニティを構築し
そしてコネクティでどんどん人と人とはつながっていくそしてその中において新しい形
というものをつくっていくということがより重要になってきます
教訓見つめ考え学ぶ人と関わり世界の中で皆さん一人一人のストーリーというものを
詰めていくということが非常に重要な時代になってきます
これで3つの共感ということになります
今日全体をプレゼンを通じてミケランジェロのダビデ像というものを入れています
大美術ををなぜ入れたのかということについて最後に簡単にお話しを差し上げたいと
思います
まずダメで像というのはルネッサンスの最高の彫刻の一つで青年期の日の究極の形状
皆さんは慶応の付属というものに入るのであれば歩いに自動的に社会において高い評価
というものを得られるようなもうすでに
状況にあるそして彫刻というものはまさにそういう受身
し
うんで必ずしも作らなくてもすでに評価されるような状況というものになっていると
いうのが皆さんの状況なわけです
そして360度という形で様々な形でだ水
移そうというものを見ていただきましたがそれは皆さん360度というような形でぜひ
周りからの評価をしてもらって見えていない
ゆっくりえいないような自分というものを気づいてまあいいデザインしていってもらい
たいというような糸コメンテーターフェーズを様々な角度から見ていただいたという
ことがあります
ん
そしてそうした中において皆さんの価値をさらに世界という中でおいて
上げていくためにはまず1回 ko あるいは
いろんな意味におけるグランドというものは脱いでですね
脱却し世界のなかで人に新しい価値で
をつくっていくということをまず考えないといけない
そしてワットから羽生よりコンピテンシー包括にしている
そして自分らしいストーリーをつくっていくということがこれから重要になってくると
思います
そして皆さんは慶応という素晴らしいコミュニティというもの同時に持っているわけ
ですからそのコミュニティというものを
アシラ会にぜひ世界の多くの人たちとにコネクテッドしてそして常に新しい価値という
ものを作っていくそしてみなさんが知らぬ間に得ている
ko というブランドから得ているもというものは単に与え
続けられているだけではなくみなさんにより世界で輝くことで結果として将来的には
慶応というブランドが課題生き続けることができるわけですね
皆さんが常に世界とどう大活躍していかなければ ko というブランドは世界の中で
忘れ去られていってしまってもへの世界の中で相手にされないブランドになってしまう
まさに皆さんのこれからの活躍というものを期待していますでもご静聴ありがとう
ございました
[拍手]